now we've got a round of would you
rather and it's a movie round of would
you rather would you rather work with a
director who gives you too many notes or
not enough zero you don't have to pay
attention all right I want too many
notes I would I prefer too many notes so
you can say no to all of them Shane is
free rein do your thing even with like
he's like look if you don't feel like
saying any of these words that's totally
cool say whatever you want
and we wouldn't is the motel scene a
good example of that
mojito scene was about 90 was about 95
percent in problem and say right yeah it
was just I was hanging out that's really
what it was yes it was so funny that
scene is actually like 10 minutes longer
but I think I think that was the only
pieces that we weren't laughing because
we were all each other laugh that entire
time I think they just took pieces where
we weren't laughing and then they were
like we can't use the recipes would you
rather get to be the hero of the movie
or get a really killer deaths and cuz
then if if you're like the hero on the
first one that you probably get to be
the hero in the second one right I can't
do both I mean I feel like you have done
that yeah have you done if I had to pick
if I had to pick I'll take the death
scene sometimes the hero because your
only job is to forward the story
straight man the straight man gets to
like you your job is to just keep
linking all the plot points together and
you don't if they have any fun how are
you thinking about this you're gonna say
hero definitely gonna say death scene
abyss like at the very end of the movie
that fits at the very end of the movie
yeah def sing deaths in death check this
movie out right here Denzel training day
got an award but next right but he was
the hero in his own mind because what he
died the hero is always the person who
takes your heart
and then takes your heart when they
leave yeah well you just want to kill
her death see yeah to me means you were
in the movie for like five minutes no
bro would you rather be a Jedi or a Sith
I'd be a horrible way to live
would you rather mess up every single
take yourself or if someone else mess up
your best take I'd rather have somebody
else my son mark do you rather have
somebody else mess up your yeah brokers
I just do it again if I mess up somebody
else's I feel bad okay ya know I could
just see why I could see what you were
doing talk to you about that just fine
no no I was always messing up my scenes
that's what would you rather have an
on-screen romance with someone knowing
that you have bad breath or knowing that
they have bad breath they have bad
breath
I'd want to know they have breath breath
and I let them off the hook but if I
have bad breath and I know that they're
not gonna let me have that book that's
how I tell everybody hundred percent
agree I'm just like I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna take the hail of bullets I'm
good I'm good to go let him do it cuz it
to me just an acting challenge yeah like
it it they're like you're making an
angry kiss would you rather have to fake
vomit or fake sneeze in a scene fake
sneeze yeah I've done fake filming for
it made me vomit in real life and also
it like a chain effect oh it's not is
that yours
noxious nice you did not just these I
was not a sneak under percent sneeze
hundred percent sneeze because the one
thing is you can actually talk sneeze
and they continue talking the worst
thing is when you know
you have to look like you're acting but
you've got goop in your mouth here like
a bunch of then she says and and he was
your father the entire time you have to
act and you're holding it for three
minutes the work is trying to act like
there's nothing into your mouth right
right and it's and it's um it's dripping
down your throat it always tastes great
the prop guys are amazing they always
make it taste great but you're just
going over crap guys you have but I like
the hose the hose is good you can talk
and go yeah but you have to talk side it
yeah like what's that parry anybody ate
the cat would you rather work with a
real animal or a CG creature real a real
animal real animal real animal attack
yeah even though WC Fields said never
walk with the kids or animals but I am
real animal every time I feel like it's
because of chaotic because who would who
would have that experience and ever pick
CG creature next exactly yeah especially
especially and we got to play the seven
cats night like it was like one cat and
the other thing is watch an actor there
when they're playing with a small animal
you're super present like you're just
like don't I would be a god-awful actor
unless the role was just to love puppies
would you rather go up against Dutch
from the original predator or a predator
Dutch today Dutch seven year old Dutch
beat the predator yeah he did he did I'm
gonna go the opposite though good
because I'm not gonna fight an old man I
would knock an old man down
you know yes I would I would never give
him the knees I would never cross the
street for you good for you I wouldn't
unless he messed with you